hey guys it's dense the founder thing
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is a review of almost human episode for
the bends or almost human goes breaking
bad yes with the new drug in town vote
yes looking for a new cook Lou cooking
that you haha oh I like this episode I
like it more than last week's it's still
episodic so I'm still that still doesn't
you know exactly exactly excite me
however I thought this was a better
episode than last week I what I liked
about it was you get the inclusion of
the other cast members yeah besides
Doreen and John you have you Rudy Rudy
the scientist guy and then you have a
Minka Kelly character and you have the
the [ __ ] cop guy as well so you have
a nice mix mix of their personnel we got
to see more of their personalities and
how they work as opposed to just that
solo team because we already know that
that they have good chemistry that doing
it on Karl Urban Michael you have good
chemistry and now we get to see some of
these other actors in play yeah I was
nicely some people get shine Rudy got
his moment you know I mean absolutely
i'm sure these next few episodes are
gonna be it's gonna probably be each
character getting their moment the Sun
they get a little screen time and it
works i mean it's it's good this little
episodic i hope we do at some point find
out what this whole in syndicate thing
is it's big in this girl that's working
for them supposedly this whole plot i
hope they don't just leave that alone
always tell me but sometimes network TV
they'll go throw you the big story in
the beginning they won't touch it to the
last few eps of the end no but i
realized i gotta build up the character
so you know this was a good episode i
was a strong episode well yet benito
martinez who are you me know from the
well the shield plays captain David
Aceveda yeah I was the show there's good
good guest stars in this and so he was a
you is a also another corrupt police
captain yeah so I like him my only
complaint is well you know you build up
this bishop secret mystery villain right
and you reel it that it's him like why
not just carry that out for longer yeah
it's like why Rizal have to
resolve in this episode I mean it does
feel like a cop procedural you know I
think it III said I do hope they bring
in the bigger story at some point I'm
still liking the show I think it's good
this episode I think a little stronger
than last week but I would like to see a
little more of the an overarching story
we'll see you how'd you like the like
the Terminator Android battle with hammy
oh girl yeah punch in there was a great
fight yeah great fight that was great a
good fight I like a special effects to
look good I mean they don't show as
quite as many wide shots in the cities
in the pilot but they still keep
everything I love in the future to make
a car future risk and put some lights on
it and just cover up like the Ford or
like GMC love even though it's the same
exact car but no I think the show looks
good for especially for a you know
network TV budget looks good yeah it
does and I just you know I'm just more
concerned about yeah let's get let's get
moving on to cuz next week's episode
looks the same like not the same episode
but it's gonna be another thing again no
we might get a little bit of trouble so
maybe we'll get her character kind of
develop more but another villain of the
week yeah crime of the week basically so
and they're not really tying these at
all to the in syndicate or whatever the
hell no I know when they start off with
that big story with a girlfriend the
connection Ellie's they haven't even
touched on many lashes like nothing i'm
like--little like oh this guy's worse
for in syndicate Oh at least maybe give
us a little something like that I don't
know I yes did you have a side of things
kind of throwing me off a little bit but
fringe was a lot like that too so
hopefully this will develop into
something else yeah hopefully by I'd say
whenever the the mid-season finale is
right right before the break that
whatever that episode is better tie into
a larger story right yeah instead of
because right right when the episode
started I even said I'm Michael looks
like we're gonna get another you know
procedural of the week and I get another
mystery of the week we gotta solve crime
of the week and it was but there are
good moments in there like I love nerd
the log cabin you know open the woods
talking and you know Carlo insist x-man
he's like thank you my friend hey thurb
answer is great yeah yeah there's a lot
of funny stuff even with Rudy you know
with trying to wear the fedora I kept
trying to like this is costume Chris
would it be James by like how at the end
they go to the bar together I would like
to see in the scene at the end of them
at the bar hanging out but I mean that
there's a good chemistry with the cast
yeah I think that's the strength of it
and hopefully they can grow beyond right
right and in that then we can you know
and also deep get deeper into the topics
in subject matters that have a little
more depth to them right you know talk
about Doreen is he really alive yeah I
can go some really like Battlestar
Galactica did that may be better than
most sci-fi tell Frank did it brings in
it yeah like what science is this
morally acceptable like going like you
know could Walter like save his son you
know how does that affect another
dimension like there's just right now
this felt like breaking bad I mean it's
like oh we had this new drug with this
new high and it's like okay but let's
just you just you know jazzing up a jet
a drug it's like do something else with
that you know something how does that
affect the society like woods what's
life like in this time period i don't
know i mean yeah we go yeah so hopefully
we get to see some more of that later no
I don't know you guys let us know what
you think you post your constable on the
website think you're calm or on our
YouTube channel think hero pro make sure
you subscribe to that when I come child
Dennis and I on Twitter let us know what
are you liking about almost human so far
we would like to see what are maybe
share with us some of your favorite
science fiction shows over the past few
years you can find us at think hero i'm
at griffin de and we asked on the
facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans make sure you like that
page and you know share and tweet our
video on various social networks that
will help us out
you